Super Champions just like they're not
looking at the scoreboard they're
beating themselves up because they could
have ran a little bit faster through the
hole even though they still won because
they're just holding themselves at the
highest standard of like could I have
done this better like if everybody who
was like I just want to be an excellent
sales professional you'd make way more
money rather than being like I just want
to close all these deals cuz
they smell commission breath you don't
listen you're just trying to close it's
a shortcut and to a certain degree it's
a little bit of laziness that's the big
difference between like in my opinion
like the people who actually become like
Super Champions and people were just
like good is that